[Music]
all right harmony welcome back
hello welcome back so nice to see you
again thank you
so you wanted to kind of explain
what happened with the uh the story you
were talking about how you got pregnant
and so on
yeah so
i mean okay basically
when i started
messing around with hoeing
and stuff like that and prostituting
i met somebody but before i was even
prostituting or anything like that i had
met
him at the mom and
he approached me said he was 18
and stuff and said he was
he was just lying about everything about
everything about him so
then some months later once i started
getting more into prostituting and stuff
i
ended up seeing him and when i see him
i ended up going with him and
being with him so that was a him and
another girl
and i was with them for some months some
months
and it got to a point where i started to
see like he was
like a pervertish like like
i started to see like pedophiles type
things like
we go around his daughter and
he would do weird stuff like
stuff you wouldn't see no father do with
to his child or you know a little sneaky
stuff like that and
i don't know it's just weird so me and
the girl used to
the girl that was there used to talk
about it like that's weird you know like
he's weird
like but it's just it was just the fact
that
i don't know he was just weird so
did he know you were 14 13 yeah he knew
he knew yeah you could pass for 20.
you could pass for 18 or 20 very easily
yeah but i told him
like about me like he i told him about
me
so then um
i had ended up going back home like
after a couple months of me being with
them i ended up going back home to where
i'm from wichita kansas
i ended up going back home and
[Music]
um they ended up sending me back out
here because
i'm going through some stuff but they
ended up sending me back out here
and when they sent me back out here i
ended up going with him
and i went with him and
i was just he was me being around him i
didn't
feel comfortable no more so like
really i was not comfortable at all
and he would try to touch you know
touch on me do stuff and then just be
like no
like that's just how like my attitude
was with him was like get off me
type stuff like i don't know i just
didn't feel i didn't like that so
then but you were working as a
prostitute yeah and you were giving him
your money
yeah the thing was with him he was we
wasn't
even going outside it was like some
whole other type stuff like some
boyfriend type stuff like it was more
like
he was just one of me and her around to
say he got two girls or
or just to feel cool or something i
don't know
but um yeah i was working for him i was
with him
and then um one night
i was we had he had got an apartment
he got an apartment like two days before
this night but
he got the apartment so we have moved
into
a new apartment or whatever me i'm
already uncomfortable so i'm like i
don't want to be staying with him
because now we in a house
you could do anything you want to me
like and i already felt weird vibes so
like the third night of me being there i
went to sleep
i was drunk intoxicated
i went to sleep and then
i was on my cycle i was on my monthly
and i remember before i was going to
sleep
he was they was telling me that i didn't
probably even mention this in the other
video but they was telling me
like that i was so intoxicated i was
trying to pick up like
stuff off the floor like tables and
stuff and
pick it up and stuff i was like i don't
know
really intoxicated so when i went to
sleep
i don't like i just he when i went to
sleep
i woke up and my panties was
way over here there was blood everywhere
it was like somebody had stripped me
like
strictly naked that's what it it felt
like somebody else struggled me naked
so when i woke up they were gone
so when they let when they were gone i
left because i just felt like it was
just weird like
i feel like they had felt like something
i felt like he did something to me i
know he did something to me
because
before i went to sleep i had pants on
and i had my drawers on so i know i
didn't take it off while i'm sleeping
like i'm intoxicated i'm slumped like
if anything i'm asleep so then
um i left while they were going
i left and then i was on
fig like two days after that i went to
fig
like i was with a new pimp
i went to fig and then
he seen me and
tried to run me over instantly like i
hurried up and backed away because i
seen i know his car
so like when he was coming i know how
his car moved because it was
it was like a bumpy type move to his car
so i seen him i was like oh
i backed up like i backed up quick off
the street
and he was like [ __ ] i should throw you
in his car and stuff like that
so then that's when i instantly started
hurry up and walking
i'm on the phone i'm calling my um
peoples i'm like
this [ __ ] he's on weird [ __ ] like i was
saying he was on some weird stuff so
then um
he started chasing us i got in the car
he started following us and
chasing us basically down so he's
we're like we're driving so fast and
he's behind us and he's
following us and he's chasing us like so
fast
we stopped and then the person i was
with he was like was like
he was basically like what's what's
going on so your your old pimp is
following you and your new pimp yes down
figaro street
yeah so then um he was like what's going
on like
he was like and then my person i was
with before was like oh free the [ __ ]
or imma shoot you with the [ __ ] in the
car or something like that so then
the new person i was with i got in the
car i mean no i was in the car he got in
the car
and then he was like forget this man
like he was just like forget it so he
just started driving off
and right here is boom boom boom i
hear his gunshots like
gunshots gunshots and then he heard a
skirt
and a big old boom like that's all you
heard like it was like
it was like somebody had shot your
tire and you skirted but really it was
him skirting he ran into a pole
a power pole big powerball so
when that happened people started taking
i didn't see this
i didn't see that happen but i heard it
but i didn't know what happened but i
didn't see him crash or nothing like
that because i was
too busy dashing getting away so
then two days later or like a week later
people started texting my phone talking
about oh you set him up and
this system and started
saying a whole bunch of stuff and then
i don't know everybody just thought it
was my fault
like no it's not he knew what he did
and he wanted to
act like nothing happened like i wasn't
gonna leave or i wasn't gonna feel
uncomfortable anymore
so that's how
that happened so then like three four
months later
i'm back at home in kansas
and i ended up finding out i was
pregnant
my mom ended up taking a pregnancy test
or whatever she took it
i mean i took it and she said with me
while i took it
and then i found out i was pregnant and
instantly i knew
like obviously like yeah it's the person
that
did what he did but because i know any
other time i'll be using protection like
i don't
you know so
when he did like i don't know my head
was just racing like i was like
confused like and then like didn't think
it was for real
but then as months go by months go by
start getting bigger and bigger and now
i'm seven months
so i'm having a girl
and yeah she the father is gone yeah her
father's wrong
he he
oh here you go and that's it's just
crazy like
your life's a for a 14 year old your
life's already a movie yeah it's already
a movie
the whole netflix series
but oh
where do you stand now you're you're
still here in l.a i'm still here in l.a
i'm
you tried you tried to go back home
after the last interview and you
yeah i went back home at least two times
since
since the last video i made i've went
home
just recently we shot one and you went
to the airport and uh
mm-hmm yes i intercepted you at the
airport
yeah they did some weird stuff to me at
the airport
following me and stuff and
they not basically
my people the people that okay right now
i'm in custody so
not custody but and children's
like i don't know how to say it but
trouble yeah
you're in trouble so
they looking for me i guess and
i just feel like it's no reason why you
should they should even be keeping me
out here because
you're just trying to get back to your
family right that's it that's all like
and
if i've been like i've went out there
two times to show them like
it's no reason that i need to be with
you tell me about
i i've talked with your mom and dad i
met your mom once but i've spoken to
your mom and
dad many times now and they seem like
really solid parents
they are like they're like
they're different i'm not gonna lie my
mom's a aquarius my little sister
aquarius i'm a scorpio my dad's a
scorpio so it's like
we all like i don't know that's my
family exactly
it's like my family is
my family like i love them to dance and
but your mom loves you and you know
she's trying to discipline you and
straighten you out but
discipline don't always work but
you're a handful but your younger sister
is not nothing like you right she's
innocent
so innocent she don't do you know
she ask her oh you want to go hang out
with somebody or
you ask her oh i got a friend for you
she's not gonna want to go she's
not gonna want to meet you she's like
she stayed there herself where did you
get this wild streak
you know what where did you pick up this
wild streak
for a 13 year old girl to do some of the
things you've done it's pretty
extraordinary
it's like i just got into it hanging
around people
hanging around girls that don't
got nothing going for themselves
is there something exciting and
attractive about that lifestyle
it's really not it's just
it's it's just a lot of drama and
i don't know a lot of
you see a lot of different stuff every
day and it's
dangerous but then you really see what
go on in the world
every day so it's like
that's a whole nother different
lifestyle
you feel like you're you're done with it
or do you feel like maybe you might
i'm not uh i had a whole
child to take care of it's no
and then i'm still me myself i'm still
young so it's like you don't even go to
high school yet
yeah and i don't want to keep doing that
and then something happened to me one
day and then my child by herself in this
world and then she ended up doing what i
do
or what i did so
yeah i cut all that when i found out i
was pregnant
i could have went back but i didn't you
know i came back out here
well i did once but that was a whole
nother different
i went to pomona yeah you told me you
told me about that
but that was that was mostly just like a
little peer pressure and you needed
some money for food right hanging out
with people but it's not like you're
i was you're hustling again and you're
back you're back at it yeah it's not i
had no pimp or nothing
i was by myself dude but yeah
lately i haven't been doing nothing
nothing like that you're just you're
just trying to get back to
wichita i'm back home to my parents so
that way i
have my baby now your mom wants you to
turn yourself in because
that'll potentially release you from l.a
and then you can go back to kansas
yeah she she don't want me to she wants
me to
and she'll say that sometime and
pressure and say oh
you need it but the next day she'll be
like
she's mixed feelings right now she's
confused too i feel like
are you confused me i know what i want
i could go back home and i have to worry
about this out here
like with this cloven
19 stuff going on anyway it's no way
they can just take you
and put you in jail or
do anything to you all court
every court that we do like and when i
go to court is on the zoom visit so
i can go to court even if i was on the
run like no but i mean
what you need to do is do whatever is
necessary so that you can get
released from la and then go back to
kansas and live your life and raise your
kid
and maybe go to high school yeah
probably gonna be homeschooled you know
everyone's homeschooling now anyway so
who knows maybe that's the answer
but i'm probably going
um i'm just ready to go home
i'm tired of being out here it's been
you want to go home yeah it's been too
long
but they don't get that yeah it's
strange to me that a
14 year old girl who's pregnant and i
ran back home twice
and has a family back there it's not you
know everyone's yeah i saw the comments
about your mom but your mom's solid your
mom's a good mom
yeah and autumn comments about her and
all of that like
that's false
my mom's she's nothing like like she's
all she want is for her kids to be happy
and to teach them the best way she can
your mom's great she's like she's not a
bad mom at all neither is my dad a bad
dad
they both still got learning to do as
much as i do
so we all go through stuff together
so all right harmony thank you for
filling us in on
some more of your details and i wish you
all the luck in the world and getting
back to your family
you're welcome all right
thank you
all right so we have some uh some news
on your
situation good good good news
going home finally
yes finally what did the
court tell you it told me that they were
gonna order
my cat they were gonna order me back to
my mom and that
they were going to drop the case when
they know i'm with my mom
good for you so that's what i think
needs to happen no i don't got to deal
with nothing you don't have to come back
to l.a
you're flying home yeah tomorrow's
or the day after that yeah good for you
plenty of time to get settled before
your baby comes yep
got two more months left that's perfect
time and i feel like
but i wish it was earlier but it's
perfect timing
so what do you what do you make of all
this drama that you've had in your life
for such a young girl i just feel like
it was all i'm not gonna say a phase
but i'm gonna say like it was all
some it was basically something i went
through in life and learned from it it's
like
when you go through crazy things in life
and then you learn from it that's
what i feel like happened it's like
i would have never knew nothing about
this
but i'm not sure 14 year old girls are
supposed to know all the things that you
know though
right but it's just i think it's in your
personality i i suspect it's part of
who you are yeah that too
i don't think it's gonna end i mean i
hope i hope you s you
turn into and go in the right direction
from here but i i suspect you may
have a very interesting life from here
on as well
yeah you can't just turn it off and be
like normal now
right i'm never gonna be how i was
before everything
happened to me happened or before
everything i went through i'm not gonna
go back you know to
before but i'm different but it's
i'm different now
so i'm gonna be going through different
stuff
hopefully you can channel it into
something more
less destructive maybe less dangerous
yeah
something that's good for you and your
baby yeah because
all this other stuff i can't
i got a whole baby to take care of
and i'm ready to take care of her too
i just was making i wanted to make sure
it was all gonna go the right
way with me taking care of her like
i don't want nothing bad to happen you
know and then
she get took and you know that's not
well on you i think your biggest fear
was losing the baby right yeah that was
my biggest fear i really didn't care
about what was gonna happen to me
but i just cared that
she was gonna be okay because
when you carry something for nine months
and then somebody come in there and say
oh
we're taking your baby i don't want that
to happen to me
yeah that's understandable it's like
a feeling that you
don't want to fail because i think a
mother's connection with your child is
probably one of the strongest
connections there is
and then especially when you have them
it's definitely going to be like a
wow like i just had my own baby like
guess
but i still got a lot to learn i'm gonna
have a lot to learn
i'm not gonna be able to even
do no more i ain't gonna be no more of
my time
it's all her time now
but i have support so
yeah well thank you for the update and i
wish you and your baby and your mom
and your family the best of luck you are
cool thank you very much
you